now and go straight to uh sam coats our
deputy political editor bringing us some
breaking news
in a very dramatic week for british
politics we have more kierstarma will
not face any fixed penalty notices fined
from durham police over the events of
the 30th of april last year durham
police after a six week or so
investigation have decided that there
isn't a case to answer for the leader of
the labour party and the deputy leader
of the labour party angela rainer over
the events in durham miners hall just a
few days before the hartlepool
by-election the police have been
investigating let's look at the
statement now from durham police that's
just been issued following the emergence
of significant information investigation
was launched by durham constabulary
about what happened in the miners hall
in red hills durham on the 30th of april
uh those the events that you can see on
your screen at the moment that
investigation has now concluded
a substantial amount of documentary and
witness evidence was obtained which
identified the 17 participants in their
activities during that gathering
following the application of the
evidential full code test it has been
concluded that there is no case to
answer for a contravention of the
regulations due to the application of an
exception namely reasonably necessary
work
accordingly durham constabulary will not
be issuing any fixed term uh fixed
penalty notices in respect to the
gathering and no further action will be
taken
they went on the investigation has been
thorough detailed and proportionate the
final evidence supplied by participants
from the local constituency was returned
to durham police on the 5th of july and
analyzed by investigators against all
the evidence before the investigation
was concluded on the 8th of july 2022 in
line with established national policing
guidelines we're not going to identify
any of those present uh and um everybody
has been informed of the outcome let's
go straight to the labour party's
statement in the last few moments a
labour party spokesperson has said
kirstama and angela ager have always
been clear that no rules were broken in
durham the police have completed their
investigation and have agreed saying
there was no case to answer we
understand that kirsten will be making a
statement this afternoon and take some
questions about what's been going on so
this is all about what happened
as you can see on your screen on the
30th of april
the allegation that was made
including by some tory supporters and
pushed very very hard by the
conservative party including uh the uh
conservative mp rick holden was that the
event that you can see at the moment uh
which effectively at the end of the day
uh kirsten had been honest was on his
way to hartlepool and that there had
been a curry and people were having some
drinks and you can see kierstarma with a
bottle of beer in his hand that that
hadn't been
reasonably necessary for work which
under covered regulations at the time
wouldn't have been acceptable because at
that point we're in step two of the road
map that boris johnson had put the
country in as we were coming out of that
particular phase of covet but that meant
at the time that you had to you could
only really
uh appear uh you could only really see
other people socially if it were you
couldn't see other people socially you
could only have gatherings if they were
reasonably necessary
for work uh there was an investigation
into kiesdama and into angelorena
about whether or not the um uh the
gathering was reasonably necessary for
the purposes of campaigning in an
election which would which would also
have been an exemption uh and that curry
uh
takeaway curry uh has been judged part
of a working event there were
more than a dozen people there and
although the event was filmed through
that window clearly durham police have
decided uh that eating at the end of the
day did not constitute a breach of the
rules it was part of the working day uh
and therefore it has not generated a
fixed penalty notice kirstama of course
if you remember uh gambled uh on this uh
on being cleared as part of this event
uh by promising to resign if he was uh
facing a fixed penalty notice uh he of
course wanted to draw a contrast with
the prime minister who did receive a
fixed penalty notice uh for the infamous
birthday party that he uh went to uh
inside downing street kissed
unprocessing to resign if he was found
to have breached the rules and issued
with a fixed penalty notice as did his
deputy angela rainer but there was going
to be huge relief at the top of the
labour party all across the labour party
that durham police have said that
there's no further case to answer after
what durham police say is a very
thorough investigation that has taken
over a month to conclude